have you ever really noticed how
sometimes a new product
isn't really all that new this kind of
thing has happened before and the funny
thing is it's not like people don't
notice just look at amd with their
pitcairn family of gpus back in 2012
through 2015. that was three whole
generations of basically the same card
under different names and it's not just
amd that pulls this rebranding and
re-badging bs
all the big players do it nvidia intel
you name it so why does it keep
happening and why is amd releasing a gpu
for the third time again i think we have
got the answer origin pc builds custom
desktops and high performance laptops
with free lifetime 24 7 tech support and
they only use high-end components like
samsung's 970 evo pro m.2 ssd visit
origin pc today at the link below for a
special promo
[Music]
okay so it's not like every product you
buy is a straight re-release
sometimes we get a high-end product in
one generation
rebadged as a mid-tier one in the next
like the geforce gtx 680 being rebranded
as the gtx 770 with a mild clock speed
bump and we also usually see a token
price reduction to go along with that
honestly no problem with that it's a
good way to get rid of old stock and
it's good value for the consumer win-win
on the other hand when a product gets
positioned the same way that it was
during the previous generation
a lot of negative press almost always
comes along with it one need only look
at last week's core i9 9980xe
which intel billed as two generations
higher than the
7980xe that it replaced even though all
they did was tune their existing chip
so then if that's the case
why does anybody do this i mean it's not
free to launch a product it's actually
more expensive than you'd probably think
you have to pay for advertising with
partner websites you've got to seed
units to oems for validation you've got
to jump through all the regulatory hoops
involved in getting fcc certification
and the like you've got to get your new
upc and ean codes and if you've pushed
clock speeds higher you might even need
to design and manufacture a new cooler
furthermore if you set aside i don't
know let's be conservative and say 50
cards to go out to just the popular
reviewers at a cost of two hundred
dollars a pop that works out to ten
thousand dollars all on its own
but believe it or not that last point is
actually where the advantages of
rebranding shine through
now very few media outlets re-review the
same product that they already reviewed
so new software driver features and
performance improvements can end up
buried under the wave of initial launch
reviews so by making that product new
again
well you create an incentive to cover it
again i mean we're not the only ones who
are eager to cover new releases because
our followers want to know about them
this drives traffic for the media
outlets channel or site and for that new
product so a hot product release can
easily generate millions of views which
if we compare to advertising with a more
traditional campaign lasting for a
review cycle yields a savings of several
times the cost so you could have
millions of engaged eyeballs that are
hyper interested in the product at half
the cost of just a million
it's an ad eyeballs seems like a
no-brainer
of course developing a derivative
product of something that you already
know works is appealing to the bean
counters and the investors as well
because it involves less risk well the r
d budget is uh approximately three
billion and this is the first one so
if anyone would like to
buy this it's three billion dollars i'm
pretty sure that that's no lie there's a
lot of r d tooling and financial dice
rolling that makes any brand new product
a really risky and therefore potentially
costly endeavor i mean just ask intel
how their 10 nanometer processors are
coming along you might not even get a
product out of it now as consumers we've
kind of just taken for granted that new
processes just keep happening because
even without moore's law apple and
qualcomm have continued to improve
generationally and then more to the
point
tweaking an existing design can result
in not only better clock speeds but also
better yields which further lowers cost
as long as the performance is still good
enough so that's another reason that it
might be ideal to release something even
when it wouldn't be financially viable
to r d and all new chip or if whatever's
in the pipeline is way behind schedule
so
the rx 590 seems to fit that description
since this is our third time seeing this
gpu and the clocks are a little bit
higher than before so this kind of
generational tweaking actually worked
out great with amd's second generation
ryzen cpus
but while ryzen's refresh had amd coming
into it from a position of relative
strength
polaris refresh again
appears to be simply
amd's hand being forced because they
know that nvidia's incoming mid-range
gpu demands some kind of answer on the
subject of nvidia more reasons for this
whole behavior nvidia has a method of
dominating news cycles in a way that amd
mercifully generally doesn't so do you
remember how it took a while after the
launch of their rtx cards for anyone to
have envy link sli numbers
i've actually had experience with nvidia
going out of their way to make it
difficult for reviewers to get multiple
cards in time for launch sli coverage
that way they get a news cycle for the
announcement a new cycle for the unveil
a news cycle for the pre-order a new
cycle for their ridiculous unboxing
embargo another for the performance
review another for sli and then finally
another one when rtx games actually
finally show up
so
here's the thing why are we so mad about
this
well there's the element of time wasting
i mean we all i mean the press in
general reviewed the 7980xe
and then we did it again when they
called it something new this makes our
lives more boring we'd rather cover
stuff that's actually new but
the more offensive thing about this
practice of not naming products properly
is that it confuses the customer
and it gets worse we haven't even really
touched on the practice of introducing
cut down products that reuse an existing
product's name both nvidia and amd have
engaged in this utterly deplorable
practice in the last couple of product
generations with the gtx 1063 gig which
does not have the same grade of gpu as
the 6 gig variant but just with half the
ram and amd's more recent rx 580 2048 sp
which isn't an rx 580 it's more like a
clock boosted rx 570 so you might think
well
just don't sweat it linus recycle your
old numbers and call it a day but the
issue is that we can't do that because a
it would be wrong and b it's not always
that simple so on our reviewer's guide
for the rx 590 for example it's said in
big bold letters amd moved to 12
nanometer finfet which sounds lower than
14 nanometer efficiency improvements
maybe no
so just like intel refusing to provide a
proper spec sheet that clarifies that
their top tier chip throttles below its
base clock in avx 512 workloads in fact
to the same level as the predecessor
amd has put it on reviewers to dig up
that the 12 nanometer they're boasting
about is just global foundry's variation
of samsung's 14 nanometer there's no
transistor shrink so it's just the same
die area for the same compute course but
with higher clock stability and that
would be fine if they weren't trying to
pass it off as a new graphics card its
suggested retail price of 280 bucks is
pretty far out there when eight gig rx
580s can be seen for 60 to 80 less many
because they're oc models with core
clocks within 150 megahertz or so so i
guess here's what we're saying some
advice free of charge
if you got nothing and all you want is
some fresh coverage of your product
be honest
call it an rx 580 plus or rx 480 plus
plus since we're on the subject and
spend that launch budget on something
else like i get the appeal of using a
relaunch to reset your msrp that was
eroded by gradually lower sales and
promotions but i would make the argument
that the only people that you're fooling
with this new product at a higher price
are really being taken advantage of
now one thing amd is doing right here is
expanding the value proposition with a
game bundle for buying an rx 590
but i'm not sure if resident evil 2 hd
the division 2 and devil may cry 5 is
exactly a blockbuster lineup
so this is the bottom line
after the core i9 9980xe fiasco
we just want to ask that manufacturers
be more transparent about how they
position and especially how they price
these derivative products not only can
proper positioning lead to better sales
and sentiment it also leads to a happier
pc gaming community
oh and by the way if anyone wanted to
know uh how the rx 590 performs it's
fine uh it's a bit faster than the rx
580 which is about what you'd expect
zoom is an online meeting and
collaboration tool that has a ton of
cool features
it supports up to a thousand
participants it can display 49 videos on
a screen it supports both hd video and
audio so you can see and hear clearly
and it's got some other cool stuff as
well it allows you to record your
meetings locally or to the cloud with
searchable transcripts it's got built-in
collaboration tools it lets you meet
securely with end-to-end encryption and
it works on your desktop your laptop
your tablet and even your mobile phone
you can try it out today with a free
account for unlimited one-on-one
meetings or pick up their pro account to
get unlimited meeting durations and more
we're gonna have a link to zoom in the
video description go check them out
so thanks for watching guys dislike if
the video sucked but if it was awesome
hit that like button get subscribed or
maybe consider checking out where to buy
the stuff we featured in the video
description again be clear rx 590 not a
bad card
just not new
also linked in the description is our
merch store which has cool shirts
nope no i'm not wearing a melty t-shirt
well it has cool shirts and our
community forum which you should totally
join